there's no blackboard or chalk or
notebooks
but there's a sparkle of hope in the
eyes of these young ethiopian refugees
trying to start a new life amid the
toughest of conditions
the makeshift school at the umra cuba
camp is sponsored by the norwegian
refugees council
one of the things we're trying to do is
to help give them a
sense of normalcy a bit of sense of
stability
by setting up some temporary learning
spaces
so they can have some classes every day
something to do but also something to to
learn from in this really chaotic period
of their life
so far we've set up 10 classes there'll
be
two shifts today we hope that that is
about 800
children that we can help in the first
instance
there's probably going to be a few
thousands children already
there's an estimated 3 000 children in
this camp
many of them had their education
disrupted when fighting broke out
between the ethiopian federal army
and their tigran people's liberation
front a few weeks ago
they were forced to flee with their
families relief agencies speak of a
number of unaccompanied children
in need of special care some are showing
signs of trauma
others are barely coping with the sudden
change in their lives
some have had it even worse the letter
sultan hasn't been able to find any
trace of his wife and two young
daughters
since the first raids on the tigran town
of hamera
by the sudanese border a few weeks ago
i just couldn't find them they could be
dead or alive but there's no idea what
happened to them
i was not home when the attack took
place people fled in every direction
they could
my family is gone we're still at the
umrakuba camp
and yes suddenly it looks like an old
place for some of the old ethiopians
here it's history repeating itself
that's because back in the 1980s this
building served as a school
for some of them as child refugees
in the 1980s refugees came here fleeing
a famine that coincided with
and resulted from years of fighting
between tigray rebels
and the central government of former
communist dictator mengistuhila mary
the animosity that conflict had created
still lingers today
here in the camp tigranes are teaching
their children
in english not amharic which is the main
official language of the federal
republic of ethiopia
a sign of the mammoth task ahead for
prime minister abi ahmed in his effort
to restore
national unity